we've got a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p i don't
think that troy york is happy with me
because he wants me to go sleep with a
mountain lion there's an idea you don't
like field mice now why don't you get
yourself a cat and do us a favor and get
their mountain with it there you go
all right well something clearly setting
off troy york there when i said I don't
know who likes field mice in their house
like is that a weird thing that when we
we did that audience question I said
yeah I don't really love mice and I've
had to deal with mice before but you're
also opposed to cats
- who doesn't like cats I don't like
cats that's true horrible that's true
yeah I'm just not a cat guy and I I
don't know apparently this is really
triggering for Troy York we've got a
fantastic bonus show for you today we're
gonna talk about a big initiative in
India to plant 66 million trees but does
this even make a dent in the
deforestation that we're seeing around
the world we will deal with that soymilk
why is it called milk it's not milk it's
made from soybeans
well even federal agencies can't agree
on what can and cannot be called milk we
will also talk about a really disturbing
trend in the car industry which is
longer and longer car loans up to an
average now of just under six years
that's the average car loan some loans
stretching to eight or even nine years
this is a disaster for personal finance
I will talk about why on the bonus show
and maybe we'll hear a little bit about
some of our fourth of July escapades you
can sign up for the bonus show and get
instant access by becoming a member at
david pakman.com slash membership the
coupon code for tea on 4th saves you 40%
for the 4th of July that expires in 24
hours the code is all one word all
lowercase 4 0 o n 4 th for tea on 4th
Pat's already picked up a couple hundred
thousand memberships at the discounted
rate and I encourage you to do the same
we will talk to you on the bonus show in
mere minutes